right so this is a mission star map of
the night sky it's a it's a little bit
big so it's a 2.8 meters tall by four
point four meters wide so it's not a
small thing to carry in your luggage on
a plane halfway around the world so it's
15 kilos as well yeah there's a bit
tricky getting on the plane so we set up
an ESP 32 chip which is listening to a
aw s IOT trigger it's got an onboard
Wi-Fi so that blue light is actually
telling me that it's having quite an
edge to AWS yet so it's just working its
way through when the blue light turns
off the main that's fine yeah let me
tell you about knitting I
I took a domestic knitting machine from
the 1980s we're talking really
old-school tech here with a 32-bit
onboard computer and and I hacked it to
turn it into a modern-day network
printer so there's a few hacks involved
with that one so first of all I used a
Raspberry Pi 2 interface between the
onboard computer and my computer so
there are three prize obviously sitting
on the network and it's running a
website which I can connect to with my
laptop and in a completely different
room and then I can send it an image and
it can process that image give me a
preview of what it'll look like in the
knitted fabric and then I can press
print and there's there's still a little
bit of work involved in actually getting
the print started physically with a
knitting machine you have to cast on
it's there's a bit of a process there
but once it's running I've got a robot
arm that's running it backwards and
forwards to actually perform the
knitting and also built with with the
help from my husband John Spencer I
built a an automatic color changer so I
can do multiple color meetings not just
black and white like multicolored
netting on this on this old-school
knitting machine normally they're
designed kind of like a sewing machine
in the sense that you sit there and you
actively engage with the Machine and
you're constantly manipulating it in
order to produce the end result which is
the Knitting so in the efforts of
automating it I took out an entire
process of creating knitting patterns so
I
extra crediting plan I create an image
and then the process will create the
pattern for me and then yeah and I've
made the actual color-changing part
which which means that I don't need to
say with a knitting machine at all once
it's running one of my major
contributions to the knitting to the
machine knitting community was a whole
new algorithm that I created to create
one knit per pixel knitting in three
colors so that's something that these
machines would never previously capable
of doing so create a whole new algorithm
in order to do that and I think the main
reason why no one had done before is
because it takes a lot of processing to
sort of think through the problem and
get it working so I could I was able to
create a few different algorithms and
then I you know been the computer
scientist I tested lots of different
algorithms and I came up with one that
cake that had the best results which is
the one you see behind me oh there go
this pices going off before this piece
was actually finished I entered it into
something called REA IO which is a
three-day hackathon that my work runs
for over three days every quarter which
is amazing and I am yeah I did a
call-out to get help is to light up the
constellations mostly laptop covers
scarves baby blankets yes oh I've done
it I've done a few things nothing quite
this big though so this was a bit
intimidating this particular project I
don't know too much about astronomy I'm
very much an amateur but I plotted where
the planets will line up on the actual
knitting's they line up to a particular
date and time and I've been working on
this project for a few months now so
it's kind of hoping that I would hit the
deadline and I did actually hit it this
tapestry was installed by or before 6
p.m. Friday the 31st which is the day
that EMS opened this knitting was
installed ready to go and the planets
aligned at that time I tell me could you
see them always the car
it was actually still daylight but it
didn't check that night and it took a
few hours later and yeah the the moon
was spot on the planets we're pretty
much in the right spot sir
yeah that was less satisfying no oh
right a few people have asked me that
question I I really want to keep it in
the public domain somewhere so I will be
taking it home with me so nothing's
really finalized there yet but yeah
hopefully people can actually come and
see it and like you know touch knitting
it's it's it's a it's a fabric it you
know people need to touch it so
hopefully today and public domain
somewhere
it took a lot longer than I was hoping
mostly because I was having a problem
with with the yarn getting caught on the
left side writing in the color changer
so I mean yarn is a fuzzy fuzzy material